hey everyone
this is shruti from simply learn welcome
to this content marketing full course by
simply learn
we'll begin this full course by
understanding what content marketing is
and some of its popular strategies then
we will see how content marketing
affects seo
and we'll understand how to rank number
one on google and youtube by creating
high quality content
then we will look into the top 10
important content marketing interview
questions
and answers at the end we will look into
minor concepts like a simple beginner's
guide to content marketing
and introduction to content marketing
certification training
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your content marketing
career related queries would have been
answered
for this training with me i have our
experienced content marketing specialist
rob and greg jabo together they will
take you through the various topics of
content marketing
so without any further ado let's get
started
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update from
simplylearn
i'm greg jarbo and what is that
i mean what we're going to talk about in
this first
module of a content marketing foundation
course
is literally content marketing okay
what is it so content marketing is not a
new concept it's been around for over
100 years in fact
one of the classic foundation stories of
you know
the birth of content marketing goes all
the way back to the michelin brothers
in france and the michelin brothers you
know
in case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know a little refresher
right now
were two brothers who made pneumatic
tires
and they were trying to sell them along
with an innovative product
at its time called the automobile
in an era where the roads were horrible
in a place france where frankly people
didn't like to get outside of paris and
into the
provinces because my god what was worth
going out there for
you know were paris that's all happening
here
and what the michelin brothers realized
is if they wanted to sell
more tires they had to get people to
drive farther and farther
and use them so what did they come up
with
the concept that really is the birth of
content marketing
in my book was the michelin guide
and the michelin guide was unique in
that it reviewed
restaurants not just restaurants nearby
in paris but restaurants
out there in the provinces
and the michelin brothers are the ones
who came up with the one two
and three star rating system to say this
restaurant
i know it's way out there it's you know
bad roads
uh but guess what to die for the
ratatouille
ah you you gotta have it this is a
three-star restaurant you
you it's worth making the trip and oh by
the way
since we're going to give you a guide
and you have to get out of
paris in order to get there we're going
to tell you where you can find
gasoline along the way which hotels
you might want to stay at overnight and
oh by the way
just in case you have to how to repair
a flat tire particularly if it's a
michelin tire because it's a
pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair
and guess what that put michelin on the
map
why they weren't trying to sell you more
tires
they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or tire repair i mean that was in there
but it was only a how-to
article not necessarily a feature and
benefit
what they were doing was they were
speaking to their audience about what
their audience was truly passionate
about which
in paris in 1900
was food and by
creating content that got the audience
to get into their new innovative
automobile and drive all the way out
there
into the provinces for that absolutely
remarkable
three-star restaurant people got more
flats
people had to replace their tires but it
was worth it
and oh by the way michelin sold more
tires
so that that's a great story every time
you sort of you know hit a pause and
like well
we're doing content marketing we need to
come up with a concept
think back to the michelin guide it's
it's great foundation so let's go
to a modern definition where are we now
in the 21st century
when it comes to content marketing well
you can read the slide here and read the
definition and some people like reading
definitions i'm not going to read it to
you
but i am going to highlight a couple of
words in the definition that i think
are absolutely critical to any
definition
of content marketing the content that
you create needs to be
relevant and it also has to be
valuable now if it's not relevant then
you're not
actually meeting my needs or interests
you know
and why would i be interested and we've
gotten way
too tired of screening out the
commercial that comes on
um you know trying to sell us snow tires
and pardon me we live in florida i don't
use snow tires what the what the heck is
this commercial
doing you know interrupting what i'm
watching
so relevance is important relevance
means that this content isn't going to
get screened out and the valuable the
valuable
can can work in a lot of different ways
it can be interesting
it can be useful you know value
is an interesting proposition all by
itself
but that's the key to content marketing
uh
it's not just creating more spam
it's not just throwing more trash over
the fence and hoping something happens
this is something where if you've
created valuable
and relevant content you know what your
customers will find
you that's a whole different kind of
proposition
i know there's some skeptics who are
saying oh come on come on come on
content marketing is just a fancy new
name for social media marketing
right and the answer is well there is
some overlap and we're going to deal
with that
in module 3. but let me just
be clear here social media content
is part of what content marketing needs
to create
but it can also create content for your
website
and that's not the social media it can
also create content that
your pr people can share with
reporters or bloggers and that's not
normally considered
social media content and by the way
all of that content can be optimized so
maybe it actually is part of seo
not social media marketing in fact
that's the other place
that content marketing really overlaps
and it's not coincidental
it so happens that around february
2011 when google rolled out the first
of its multiple versions of the panda
update
all of a sudden even seos started to pay
attention
to content marketing why because google
changed the rules
and what google basically said is if
your content isn't valuable
or relevant you know what it's not going
to rank very well in our search and
algorithm
and all of a sudden people who had been
used to like putting keywords in the
right places
realized content matters i mean i've got
to actually tell stories that are
interesting
i've got to create information that's
valuable
yeah you can make it relevant that's the
optimization part
but you know if you're trying to
optimize a piece of boring
irrelevant trash god bless you good luck
so yeah content marketing has grown
it's like tripled in terms of web search
interest
since the panda update and we're talking
about panda 1
of course there was panda two painted
three panda four i mean come on
google is driving us in this direction
and so
content marketing is pretty relevant
today
now one of the other things that uh
people in content marketing struggle
with is oh
but you don't understand i do b2b
content marketing
or i'm a small business or part b i'm an
enterprise
and so content marketing has to come in
flavors right
well possibly maybe on occasion
so let's just question that assumption
for a second
you know content marketing has been
around now long enough and enough people
have done it
that some research has been conducted
and has been conducted
against b2c marketers and b2b marketers
and small
business marketers and enterprise level
marketers
and when they start asking key questions
like okay
we're going to try to determine what is
the difference between an
effective content marketer and an
ineffective
content marketer let's see the results
well first of all the most important
thing
to be an effective b2c
content marketer is you need a
documented
content strategy okay
all right i mean people who are winging
it aren't as
effective as people who actually have
thought about this and written it down
got it okay no great insight but you
know
interesting to note secondly they've got
to have somebody in charge who oversees
content marketing
oh lord does that mean we have to have a
reorg or maybe we just have to designate
somebody
who reports to somebody else whatever
but
guess what it really helps if somebody
is driving this process
third they've got to be using more
content marketing tactics
than their less effective peers
and this is not an argument more is
better this is just
pardon me that's the way the data falls
out the people who are
actually more effective are doing more
different kinds of
things a broader range of tactics
and who knows maybe it's that broader
range that's part of the success formula
same thing is true with social media
platforms
the effective content marketers are
using
more than the ineffective ones and last
but not least and this may be a sort of
a result of the first four
by gosh effective content marketers
generally have greater percentage
of the overall marketing budget in their
organization
wow okay that's the b2c marketing forum
but you don't understand
i'm not a b2c marketer okay
so let's take a look at the b2b content
marketing formula
guess what you need to have a documented
content marketing strategy to be an
effective
b2b content marketer you need to have
someone who oversees content marketing
strategy
it helps if you are using more tactics
and more social media platforms and
guess what
you spend a higher percentage of your
overall marketing budget
on content marketing well that's similar
to the b2c content marketers
but you understand b2b is different yeah
there's a couple of small differences
but guess what
overall the top five criteria
are similar and when you get to small
business
here's what you're going to see same
five
criteria and you're in an enterprise
i know the world is different for
enterprises actually not so much
so four different data points let's net
it out
there's a pattern and the pattern is is
i don't care what flavor of content
marketer you are
you can be b2c b2b you can be small
business you can be
large enterprise at the end of the day
there are
five things that you've got to focus on
if you want to be effective we've
already
covered these and are there differences
between
small businesses and large enterprises
between b2b and b2c
well sure but they're all at the margin
what's the downside if we don't do this
you know is anyone going to come in and
like wacus
and the answer is um maybe not inside
your boardroom
but it may happen on the next sales call
that one of your sales people makes
they may encounter someone i like to
call the man in the chair
and the man in the chair actually refers
back to a classic
mcgraw-hill ad campaign from i think the
1960s
but basically the guy in the chair asks
theoretically
some questions from quote maybe your
sales person
okay i don't know anything about you
i don't know about your company i don't
know about your company's
product i don't know about your
company's you know reputation
or anything about you and so what was it
you were going to try to sell me
and that's the downside of not having
a content marketing program
content marketing has been around for
over 100 years
but in the online world customers are
behaving
in lots of new ways and they're
consuming content
on various kinds and types of devices
that changes things content marketing is
now about creating content that
consumers will engage with and act upon
not just read or listen to
or watch so in this introductory module
we're going to provide you with an
understanding of how content marketing
affects the decision making process
when people are on the customer journey
to making
a purchase and with a solid content
marketing strategy
your customers buying decisions
can actually happen faster you can
basically
shorten the decision-making process and
you can reach and expand to new
prospects
so one of the things that we hope that
you're going to
learn after basically taking this module
you should be able to do the following
first of all
you can define content marketing and
other related concepts
secondly you should be able to explain
why content
needs to be relevant and valuable
in order for it to be effective third
you need to describe the overlap between
content marketing
seo social media marketing
fourth you need to name five traits of
effective content marketers and
last but not least you need to explain
the benefits
of content marketing these are our
objectives
and hopefully they're going to be your
learning
outcomes so content marketing
is not a new concept it's been around
for over 100 years in fact
one of the classic foundation stories of
you know
the birth of content marketing goes all
the way back to the michelin brothers
in france and the michelin brothers you
know in case you haven't done your
history that's okay you know
a little refresher right now were two
brothers
who made pneumatic tires and they were
trying to sell them along with an
innovative product at its time called
the automobile
in an era where the roads were horrible
in a place france where frankly people
didn't like to get outside of paris and
into the provinces because my god what
was worth going out there for you know
for paris it's all happening here and
what the michelin brothers realized is
if they wanted to sell
more tires they had to get people to
drive farther and farther
and use them so what did they come up
with
the concept that really is the birth of
content marketing
in my book was the michelin guide
and the michelin guide was unique in
that it reviewed
restaurants not just restaurants nearby
in paris but restaurants
out there in the provinces
and the michelin brothers are the ones
who came up with the one two and three
star rating system to say
this restaurant i know it's way out
there
it's you know bad roads but guess what
to die for the ratatouille ah you
you gotta have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip
and oh by the way since we're going to
give you a guide
and you have to get out of paris in
order to get there we're going to tell
you
where you can find gasoline along the
way which hotels you might want to stay
at overnight
and oh by the way just in case you have
to
how to repair a flat tire particularly
if it's a michelin tire because it's a
pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair
and guess what that put michelin on
the map why they weren't trying to sell
you more tires
they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or tire repair i mean that was in there
but it was only a how-to
article not necessarily a feature and
benefit
what they were doing was they were
speaking to their audience about what
their audience was truly passionate
about which
in paris in 1900
was food and by creating
content that got the audience
to get into their new innovative
automobile
and drive all the way out there into the
provinces for that
absolutely remarkable three-star
restaurant
people got more flats people had to
replace their tires
but it was worth it and oh by the way
michelin sold more tires so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of
you know greetings everyone and
welcome my name is rob sanders from
simply learn
and today we're going to talk about
content marketing strategy
so buckle up and let's get right to it
and we're going to get right into some
of the best practices some tips
some methodologies some things you
should be doing with content marketing
so right out of the gate let's start
talking about
knowing your audience okay so content
is all about writing for a particular
audience
so it's just like speaking except when
we're speaking to somebody
we're speaking directly to them content
is very similar
and so we have to be able to know our
audience ahead of time
so what you can do is collect
demographics
of your target audience based on who's
coming to your website so you can get
that data in google analytics
under audience email subscribers i mean
who is subscribing to your emails who do
you already have in your email database
and you can look at social media i mean
you look at facebook you can look at the
people who are already connected to you
okay these are just some three three of
many examples you could be doing
to gather data on your audience
okay you have to know who your audience
is before you start
writing you know for a successful
content marketing strategy you really
just need to know your audience
and basically you're going to segment
them based on their
interest so that content is going to be
catered to
that audience okay so if it signs that
likes a specific
you know product uh that you offer or
feature that's part of that product that
you offer then
that's the segment you're gonna be
writing about so you need to collect
your
data on your audience ahead of time and
then you're gonna segment that audience
okay so you're not gonna write content
for everyone
because the shoe doesn't necessarily fit
for everyone
okay the shoe has to fit for specific
foot
and in this case we're talking about an
audience we need to be able to segment
our audience out
and you could certainly segment them out
by age by gender by education level
by income by interest i mean these are
just some of the examples again
it could be new returning or new reusers
versus returning users it could be
users who have purchased from you in the
past versus users who haven't purchased
from you in the past
it could certainly be an age range or it
could be
even going further on interest level or
combination thereof okay so for example
you can get that demographic information
using google analytics
just got to go in analytics under
audience
under demographics you're going to see
age and br it's
age is broken out by age range and
you're going gonna see gender
so you're gonna see a breakdown of
gender and use that to your advantage so
if you're going to you know write some
content and you know
99 of your traffic is female
the age of 18 to 24 then you know that
content's been catered accordingly
so we could certainly go to facebook
page insights and get some really good
demographic data there because facebook
is all about demographics
okay so you could see exactly
you know how many fans you have broken
out by
men versus women and then you can see
again
same thing as google analytics you could
see an
age range breakout you could use twitter
analytics
i mean twitter has share some really
good insights into education level
so you know if you're dealing with you
know highly sophisticated people
who have master's degrees or even higher
or let's just say even on linkedin
you know that majority of the people
you're trying to target
are c-level meaning ceos
or cfos or cmos you know chief
marketing officers or chief executive
officers then
you're going to cater your message a
little bit different than say
mid-range managers or or you know
even high-range managers or even vps
so use your audience information you
collect on these various platforms to
your advantage
okay so let's jump into number two we
want to create
high quality content now i know this
sounds like a given
but and i say but heavily
there's not a lot of high quality
content out there on the internet so
separate yourself
first and foremost always always always
create high quality content it's gonna
result
in a lot of things are gonna benefit you
you know one you're gonna come across as
you know somebody who knows what they're
talking about and that's gonna help
increase your brand awareness okay when
you increase your brand awareness people
know about you so it's
likely going to increase traffic to your
website
or if you're on social media you know if
you produce
good high quality content people are
gonna share that content
okay so from an seo perspective it can
improve
website ranking meaning if you have good
quality
content you know and it's really focused
in on a specific topic or a certain set
of core
words keywords then you're gonna rank
improves website dwell time meaning hey
you get good content people are going to
hang around to see what else you have to
offer okay
so it's no secret that you know good
content
you usually leads to you know quality
engagement
and then certainly last but not least
you can gain a lot of leads here
meaning hey somebody likes what you have
to say whether it's a video or blog post
or or
infographic you know people are going to
become more interested more engaged
spend more time and that's all going to
funnel through
to somebody taking that next step in the
funnel
and becoming more interested in your
service or even
purchasing one of your products so
creating high quality content involves
brainstorming topics and terms you know
you got to do the upfront work
due diligence is at work here so
brainstorm some topics
use a keyword research tool to gather
results so if you have a topic
you know one of the benefits of quality
content is
rankings go to google's keyword planner
understand how much quality and and
understand how much competition each
keyword has or understand
how much volume each keyword has that's
what's available in google's keyword
planner or any really any keyword
planning tool
you always want to create original
content okay so
you don't want to plagiarize or take
somebody else's content
and then you want to support that
content with compelling headlines so
if you have a piece of content you got
to get somebody's attention
write a nice headline that's going to
grab their attention
okay so give valuable content to readers
and add resources from well-known sites
so if you
you do borrow say a data point from
another
source then you know cite that source
you also want to create engaging and
thought provoking content get somebody
to think i mean people are going to rage
your content because they
not they don't know the subject matter
their interest in the subject matter and
they want
to be able to spend the time taking
something away from that content
follow a logical structure and use
relevant images
i can't stress this one enough you know
just throw things on
a web page you know put some structure
to it maybe you have to break it out
if you feel like you have too much
content there's no harm in breaking it
into part one versus part two
get people uh tease them a bit get them
to come back and read part two
okay use different content forms in case
somebody's interested maybe you want to
capture some data
you know prefer short paragraphs to make
the content readable
remember if you're talking to c-level
folks
you know maybe you don't have to dummy
down the content so to speak but if
you're dealing with
you know folks or people that are right
out of high school or still in high
school
then adjust your content and format and
paragraphs accordingly
and then update the content as well just
because you publish it
doesn't mean that it's done i mean when
we're talking about a web page we're
talking about
something that is actively changing or
can
change the medium that is dynamic okay
so if a data points change go back in
and update that data point
and then let people know about it
because they may want to come back and
and
you know check in to see how much that
data points change
so these are all you know good takeaways
for creating high
quality content there's some other
things that you should be aware of
you know grammatical mistakes you know
you need to avoid those there's no
reason for grammatical mistakes today's
technology doesn't allow for it
and hey listen we all have friends we
have colleagues
my desk is sitting next to a colleague
who's more than happy
to read something before it gets
published so take advantage
of the resources you have available no
reason for it because if you have a
grammatical mistake
you've just lost a lot of credibility
you know don't be afraid to add a clear
call to action at the end of your
content if somebody's interested in
reading it they're probably going to be
interested in taking the next step
whatever that next step is
okay so creating content that fulfills
viewers requirements
meaning if somebody's searching for
something and your content shows up in
the search results
then they're actively looking for you
what are you offering them
is it fulfilling their requirements you
know don't be afraid to use examples
throughout your content
in fact work in or integrate some case
studies in there
show clear examples to stress your
points
and then just don't put words on a web
page you know so
break up that content with an image
that's going to be
visually appealing okay you can add
images from public domain
sites meaning stock imagery if that's
what's going to help
create visually appealing content and
then
give more information to your audience
and we say prefer to give more
information
meaning hey going back to the content i
was saying about breaking it
up organizing it if you have more
information
you don't withhold it have them come
back and read a
secondary blog post or secondary piece
that supports the original
now we want to move from high quality
content to
running a b test baby test's so
important
why because with a b split testing you
can increase your conversion rates
okay so four elements to test and your
content marketing strategy
so if you have content say a blog and
you're testing that blog
you know test out the images test out
the forms
do you have a long form or short form
you know test out the content length
you can have a variation that is a lot
shorter than the original
does that increase or decrease bounce
rates play around with call to actions
your call to actions do matter you know
do you want to use a softer call to
action a softer tone or do you want to
use something very direct and strong
you know test call to actions to see
what's going to get people to move
closer
through the closer to purchasing and
through that funnel
so a b testing to me is something that
should be naturally done
with google optimize it's free so with
images
you know you could test a lot of
different variations of images anything
from
people to you know outlandish imagery to
just something very stock and neutral
but just make sure that those images are
relevant to the post
you know test the length of that content
you know again
if you know that your average time on
page is very low
you know don't write something very long
write something
that you think is going to stick with
that time on page but on your a b test
create something maybe a little longer
if it's engaging enough maybe somebody's
going to stay a little bit longer on the
page so
you know create a variation it's going
to play with that length okay so use
analytics to your advantage
to figure out as a baseline what amount
of content is getting people to stay on
the page
then see if you can push the envelope
one way or the other okay
improving the page with sign up forms
really what you want to do is create a
user friendly experience so
when you have sign up forms and don't
make them
non-intuitive don't make them difficult
you know
link maybe up to facebook or google so
if they're creating an account they can
create an account via google or facebook
or you know don't put too many forms on
the page
and then on those ctas as i mentioned
play around with the tone you can also
play around the color i mean i test
color all the time believe it or not
color
does matter don't use red use green
people react to different colors but
again you have cultural variances as
well so you got to take that
into account if you're in the middle
east or the far east asia
you know color schemes and what you say
matters
and it changes versus say you know
europe or the west
okay so keep that in mind when you're
making changes on color or
tone or placement and things of that
nature so you want to conduct
a competitor analysis so we're talking
about creating high quality content
testing that content you know
brainstorming some topics
you know looking at your audience you're
doing all this work you might as well
take the next step
and figure out what it is your
competitors are doing so
you can opt for competitive analysis by
identifying your competitors top
performing content
for specific topics okay and so
really what we're trying to do here is
improve our conversion rates
so what are your competitors doing what
are their baselines
we can maybe up that annie i mean that
data
is also available in google analytics so
you can look at
benchmarking reports in google analytics
to get some form or fashion
you can also go to facebook and look at
your competitors facebook pages and see
what's performing in terms of engagement
but what you want to do is find out your
strongest competitors by using
search engines or check which websites
are competing with you
and again that could include facebook as
well or
maybe even linkedin so you go with the
search engine route you can always type
in that coveted
keyword that you want to be found for
see who's ranking ahead of you
and you can see the metadata meaning the
title tag and the meta description you
can
actually see hey what are these guys
writing that's getting them
recognized in the search engine rankings
so you can certainly if you go to search
engine route you could certainly
leverage an seo platform like search
sem rush or moz or something like that
that's going to allow you
to get some good insight on competitor
information
so keep in mind there are seo platforms
that will
give you information on your competitors
and that's what these seo platforms are
good for
so number five moving on choose a
suitable
content format so now we've done all
this homework
we know what we want to say we know who
we want to say it to we're ready to do
some testing but
we need to find a format because it's
not always about
a web page per se meaning content on a
web page there's not always about a blog
post
with content in that blog post okay we
need to decide the type of content
that's going to fit what we're trying to
say so
again you can go the traditional route
with
just posting a blog post and there's
nothing wrong with that because with a
blog post you can incorporate
video and imagery you could also go a
more harder route when i say harder
more i say official route with an e-book
or case study
something that a user is going to be
able to take away
with maybe download okay something more
official um something more in-depth
something with a harder stamp on it so
that that shows individuals that you've
taken the time you've done this
homework you've done this research
you've done some really in-depth
analysis
and now the proper format for that is
not a blog post
it's an ebook now if you're into talking
like i
am then you can certainly do a podcast
and podcasts are always popular
depending on the topic
so you got to be aware of the topic now
videos are always always a good option
you got the
likes of video and video and youtube and
some other
you know video platforms out there that
allow you the ability to
get found very quickly especially with
the likes of youtube
you know people use youtube before they
go on to purchasing a product
so think about that so if you're trying
to get somebody if you're trying to sway
an audience to
move from being a brand awareness and a
loyal
you know customer to taking the next
step okay to purchasing more or
purchasing for the first time
and so videos kind of help convey that
now if you're trying to convey a lot of
different
points then an infographic might be your
best option
instead of having to write out all those
points you know try using an infographic
to convey those points
visually now again with blog posts it
should have
valuable content that can be shared by
your website
visitors on social so that's the key
make sure you have those
shareable social icons now with ebooks
it should have longer in-depth content
so
and it shouldn't be published frequently
so maybe if this is something you're
doing annually
then ebook could be the format with a
case study
what you should have a customer story
that succeeded
in and you solving that customer's
problem
so the case study is always there for
you know somebody to get an idea of what
you're all about
infographic is just visualizing data in
a more
organized way in a more visual way so
somebody understands what you're trying
to convey
now with that podcast again suppose your
audience doesn't have an
interest in reading again it could be a
certain age
certain gender a certain culture hey
everybody absorbs information
differently
so think about it ask yourself is a
podcast the best way to communicate
to my target audience and then videos
are highly engaging
they're also shareable on blog posts
and pretty much most if not all social
media platforms
so once you've done that once you choose
the proper
format you want to choose a content
management system that's going to work
for you
so you want to be able to choose
something where you can plan
appropriately produce manage publish and
measure results
all in one place there are plenty of
content management systems out there
that will help you do all of those
things okay so some examples are
wordpress hubspot
binder i mean we can list hundreds if
you're into blogging
you know wordpress is the way to go if
you're into building out landing pages
that you want to
you know share you know hotspot could be
the way to go
okay there are lots of available options
out there
so moving on number seven target your
audience using emails
okay so what are we talking about well
we all know what emails are
emails help us to communicate directly
with our target
audience and convert them to leads so
email is a good
way to follow up with your audience so
if you've done a podcast
follow up with an email you maybe get
them to
you know fill out a survey via email
based on that podcast
or if you create a podcast about some
data that you talked about in that
podcast
follow up that with with them via email
with an infographic perhaps okay built
into the email okay there's lots of ways
that all these formats can complement
themselves
via email okay you could certainly take
a blog post
and package it into an email and have a
link pointing back to the blog post
maybe as a teaser or if you're doing a
series
a series of blog posts you know you
could tease that in an email
so an email is a good way to you know
follow up with your target audience
indirectly or directly when we say
indirectly
you know you can collect emails and send
out those emails
with you know certain information or
what you should be doing is targeting
and segmenting your emails just like you
are your content so
if you're producing content for a
certain audience then make sure that
particular audience gets that same email
now some of the email content that you
could share with your target audience
are newsletters okay seasonal emails
promotional emails
automated messaging and what we mean by
automated messaging hey
if somebody just purchased from you send
them a thank you email
maybe follow up a couple days later with
another email with a survey
or what you could do is if you know who
your loyal customers are you target them
with a promotional email so there's lots
of ways to slice and dice
content via email okay just make sure
you know your target audience is
there's lots of things you can do in
email again you can complement
lots of different formats within email
as i mentioned before with a podcast or
a blog post
so keep all that in mind email's a good
way
to communicate with your audience okay
the last point we want to make here is
use native ads
okay so we talk about native ads it's
one of the smartest ways to connect
your audience with your brand so for
example
this is a native ad on buzzfeed okay
it's about
15 bands that probably won't exist
without
led zeppelin okay so for you folks out
there that don't know who led zeppelin
is a rock group
from the 70s late 60s 70s
okay disbanded in 80 81 82
early 80s okay but you know people grew
up like myself listening to led zeppelin
okay so you could see the headline here
15 bands that probably won't exist with
the outlet zeppelin
you know i'm interested in who those
bands might be even if you don't know
who led zeppelin is
okay you might be inquisitive to say
okay
who is this led zeppelin group and what
are these 15 bands
the key here is not to say the headline
or led zeppelin per se
but it's a native ad and it's sitting
next to
content talking about music okay so
according to forbes online audiences are
25
more likely to look at a native ad than
at a banner
and so that native ad in this case we're
talking about music
needs to be sitting or accompanied
alongside
content talking about in this case music
you know would help if it was rock music
just music in general might get enough
to get
peak people's interest okay so if you're
going to create content
you know align that content with
something that's
you know naturally going to fit and
that's why we call them
native ads because they're native to the
content that
they're associated with so finally after
all that's said and done
when all you've done is create good
content
follow up via emails targeting your
audience
and associating that content with you
know content
natively then you can always measure
your content performance so
my favorite part of it all you going to
analytics going to facebook insights you
know
you want to go in and check out how that
content's performing
and you want to do that because you want
to be able to see what's performing
what's not performing
the key here is associating
the content with kpis that's really the
key
so measuring the right metrics can help
you understand whether your content
is engaging or not so again measuring
the right metrics okay so when we're
talking about a video
you're not necessarily going to look at
page views you're going to look at video
views
so you know some of these basic metrics
of users and sessions and pages
bounce rate you know dwell time that's
all great but you just need to make sure
that you're aligning the right metric
with the right asset
so for example if you have a case study
or ebook
you want to make sure that you're
measuring how many
downloads the ebook or the
case study received again with the video
you want to measure
video views now if you're packaging up
emails
and sending them out to your target
audience you want to make sure you look
at open rates and click rates
okay so a lot of things you can be
looking at so make sure you choose the
right metrics because there's
hundreds and hundreds of metrics to
choose from so
just be aware all the different metrics
that are available
you know if you're in it for search okay
how much traffic getting from search
where are you ranking
so there are a lot of things you need to
think about so think about
the content that you're producing and
think about how you want to be able to
measure that content
so let's go back over our checklist here
so what you could do is create an
editorial calendar
in fact i would highly suggest you
create an editorial calendar in order to
keep track
of all the content you've done over a
period of time
are you making your content worth
reading that means
are you checking the results of that
content
what we just went over measuring the
content is it worth reading
have a column set up in that editorial
calendar you know performing or not
performing if it's not performing
don't do it again okay curate your
content
okay you always want to you know make
sure you're reusing or using or
adding to the content that you've
created
guest post on influential blogger
websites
you want to add statistics numbers and
quotes to your content
make it engaging make it look like
you've done your homework
you could share all your content not
just on social media but
you know platforms like slideshare now
you can
share it on all social media platforms
i'd highly recommend it
and again you can even repurpose it as a
blog post
so if it's a podcast then you know you
can recite that podcast
in the form of a blog okay so get some
testimonials
that support some of your content again
create a podcast you can send out an
email with a survey or
trying to solicit some testimonials or
if you post something on facebook
you know leverage the feedback you get
from facebook in the form of a
testimonial
okay and then you want to promote your
blog post for maximum success
and a lot of that means seo so make sure
you do your due diligence and
get the right keywords in that blog post
okay so you can create personas for
different user audiences
okay so remember it's all about tone
okay so if you're going to create a blog
post
make sure your tone is aligned with that
right audience
whether that be young middle-aged or
older
are you choosing the right type of
content okay you'll know
based on the results okay you want to
add h1
and h2 tags on your web pages why
because
when we're talking about content we're
talking about organizing the content
and h1 and h2s help you organize
the content appropriately customize the
metadata metadatas
title tag and meta tag descriptions and
even alt tags
okay all of that is for search so you
want your content to show up in search
whether that's video
infographic or blog post all of it can
be shown
in search results so make sure you write
a good title
and make sure you write a good meta
description because that's what people
are going to see when they search
okay so you want to create a detailed
summary and title
and again that goes along with the title
tag a meta description
and then you want to make it easy for
the audience to ask questions and
comment on your blog so don't be afraid
like i'm gonna do right now in this
video is if i'm missing anything from
this checklist
feel free to comment hey i've written my
fair share content but i could be
talking to an audience that is just as
qualified as i am
and they may have some tips so feel free
to comment
underneath this video now don't be
afraid to ask just like i just did
people are always willing to provide
constructive
feedback so don't be afraid to ask for
it and make it
easy so to me every blog post needs to
have
some form of a comment box because blog
posts are out there to solicit
engagement
now let's recap everything we talked
about because we certainly covered a lot
and there's a lot to cover when it comes
to content marketing
so one know your audience again you can
lean on google analytics
you know demographic data whether it be
age or gender
you could do the same with facebook and
twitter and linkedin
you know every platform has some data
you could take away
create high quality content when i mean
high quality content
brainstorm some topics has it already
been written to death about
or is this unique you know don't write
something your competitors are writing
okay don't copy what your competitors
have written
organize your content support it with
good imagery
all of these are tips to creating high
quality content okay when you create
that content think about running to
maybe test
you know run some variations and switch
out the
image switch out the call to action see
what's going to get people to react and
engage with the content
conduct competitor analysis so lean on
the facebooks of the world
to see what your competitors are posting
see what's engaging for them
okay you can also lean on these seo
platforms like
sem rush and moz all you got to do is
plug in a domain and they're going to
give you some information about
where a particular competitor ranks for
keyword or how many
backlinks and what websites are linking
to them
so all that's available in these seo
platforms
okay so you want to choose a suitable
content format
we listed a few from ebooks to case
studies to podcasts to infographics to
blog posts to videos
it's up to you what you think is best
for your audience
just keep in mind you need to be able to
measure it
and so that's the important thing if it
doesn't work the first time out
then you might want to consider changing
out the content format
choose a content management system you
know plenty out there
wordpress is a good one if you're going
to be a blogger okay blogging allows you
to you know post optimize that blog post
you know you could have the ability to
share that blog
post across social platforms and
you can also have that blog post show up
in search engine results so
you can't do any of that without a good
content management system
so you want to target your audience
using emails okay
so email is a good way to again
further communicate with that particular
segmented audience
and again you could use it to send out
promotional emails to loyal followers
or you you can use systematic emails
to send an email a thank you email
somebody purchases and then another
follow-up email
and again you can repurpose some of the
content you've done
in another format in the form of an
email so you know if you created a video
you know put that video in the form of
an email and send it out to your
audience to make sure they're not
missing out on that video you just
created
so lots of ways to use email take
advantage of email
it's your ally here okay use native ads
okay don't be afraid to put that content
and pair it with some other content
on another website it's been proven
people are going to engage
in an ad that they see based on the
content they're currently reading
because the ad if it's native it's going
to be
similar in nature to the content they're
currently engaged in
and then measure your content
performance i can't say this enough
make sure you're leveraging google
analytics
okay with google analytics or facebook
insights or twitter
or linkedin or any other platform you're
running on
they're gonna have data on what you've
posted so
take advantage of it align your kpis so
if it's an e-book or case study
don't measure just traffic measure how
many people are actually
downloading them
in most organizations the people who are
doing search engine optimization have
been doing it for a while
and i can tell you because i've been
doing it for a while that in the old
days
it was mostly technical with a little
bit of content sprinkled in
so for arguments like let's say 80 20.
80
of what an seo needed to learn how to do
had to deal with you know you know your
meta tags your metadata you know
uh cms systems even blah blah blah
and oh by the way yeah you need some
content on the page
well here we are a long time past that
and if this you you you look through
this uh slide here for example
uh this is the latest guidance from
google
on the kind of content they want
and if you look through the list here
most of the items on it aren't technical
and frankly most of it is content and if
you think about it
what this means is is that the job
description for seo has changed
dramatically
particularly beginning with the panda
update but then including the
penguin update and then hummingbird and
pardon me
more and more and more seos had better
be interacting with the people who are
creating
quality content engaging content
credible
content useful content
it's not enough just to put keywords in
the right places anymore
on pretty thin content that won't get
you where you want to go
so again different uh
paths maybe the same direction but the
folks in content marketing and the
folks in seo frankly need each other
and they may or may not recognize it in
your organization but you know
it's a starting point this is a
conversation you you probably need to
have content marketing is complex
it often overlaps with other
elements of marketing uh
the the most typical overlaps are with
social media marketing
and seo and uh there probably
already are in your organization
those kind of groups the seos may be on
one floor and the social media marketing
people may be in a different building
you know whatever
but the new success formula says
we got to get all those folks to the
same table now we may have to do it
virtually we may have to use you know
webinars
in order to hold those kind of meetings
who knows
but the point is is that uh you know the
world is shifting
and organizational structures need to
shift
with it and again you know that's not
something you can change tomorrow
but that is something that will evolve
over time
and for what it's worth it turns out
that let's just say
the people who are in seo
they may or may not admit it at first
but they absolutely need to work with
the people in content marketing
why because basically after
panda and penguin the rules shifted
and it's less about your title tag
and it's most mostly focused now on
the quality of your content
and whether that content is link worthy
which means it's really compelling
content
it's remarkable content that's content
that's gonna
get people to link to it because wow
that's
you know and that's not necessarily part
of the skill set that was required to be
a successful
seo five years ago or 10 years ago
so again you got to get these folks to
the table they've got to work together
you know and um and again that means the
organizational structure probably needs
to shift
and the same is true with the social
media marketing folks
you know they went out and their initial
goals and objectives were you know get
lots of likes
you know get lots of fans get lots of
views
gets lots of twitter followers why
because that seemed to be
the metric that the platform gave us
and so we used it to measure success
well it turns out
none of those measures actually measure
real success
because they're focused on being
successful on the platform
boy i have lots of fans as opposed to
being successful in business
wow that generated lots of leads and
sales
so there is a real real discrepancy
between let's just say the center of
gravity
okay it's not facebook you're not going
to make
a lot of money on facebook
you know that's just not set up to do
business
you've got to get those folks that
you've engaged in facebook
to your website where they can buy
something
and that's a you know radical shift
for all the folks who uh are in social
media marketing to say wait wait time
out
but that's not what i was told a couple
years ago and the answer is
that's correct what we've learned over
time is that being engaging is useful
if it's harnessed to a benefit and i'll
tell you
in most organizations the social media
marketing people are under
cloud because they aren't delivering
business
benefit and they too
need to learn to work with the content
marketing people
in order to do that and in some cases
they may not be creating the right kind
of content
that actually generates leads and sales
as opposed to
you know is inexpensive to create to get
my next
fan or my next twitter follower
so the key metrics here are no longer
how many likes or comments or shares did
you get
that's nice but
how many sales leads did you generate
what percentage of those converted into
sales
that's a radical change but again it
helps
when the social media marketing people
are at the table with the content
marketing people
greetings everyone this is rob sanders
from simply learn and today we're going
to talk about
how to rank number one on google high
quality
content and talk about the impact
content has
on your ability to get your website
ranked number one on google so let's
just say
you have content on your website and the
content is ranking on
you know page four of google and it's
that blog with ice cream recipes
and if it's just content for the sake of
content is not
really informative then it's not
necessarily going to get good engagement
in the eyes of google you know they want
to rank content that's very informative
it's very fresh it's exciting to read
it's interesting
it's going to have good engagement so if
it's a recipe
or an article about any topic if it's
the content is just not
informative then you're not going to get
good engagement
and when you don't get good engagement
if people don't stay on the site
to engage in the content and they just
leave the website after landing on the
page
causing a bounce then the content is
just going to continue to fall
down the rankings and we want to prevent
that we want to move up the rankings we
want to be number one on google we don't
necessarily
want to fall in the rankings for our
content so content is a key
driver in being able to rank number one
on google
so if the content is on page nine what
can we do well we want to be able to
you know take that content and do
something with it we
feel like we did write engaging content
so let's go ahead and share it on social
media
and to me social media is a good
platform to share your content because
on social media platforms like facebook
for example
you're building a community on that
platform that community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe
especially in the summer time and you're
engaging with your community on that
platform
then the likelihood of that community on
that platform
is going to increase engagement
increased engagement
will send social signals to the search
engine that says hey
this content is good quality likewise
for any other platform
most social media platforms have
engagement metrics
and those engagement metrics pass
signals
is it good is it not good do we like
this content are we giving it a thumbs
up
are we going to want to follow it are we
going to want to share it and so
if you share content that you feel is
engaging on
social platforms then it's going to be
engaging and it's likely going to cause
an increase in engagement for example a
decrease in bounces
and once you share that quality content
then
the likelihood of it moving up the
rankings even as far as number one on
google is going to be greater so you
always
want to start out writing good quality
content so let's talk about
good quality content because google does
take content seriously they do take into
account what other people think of that
content so high quality content
is an important factor so how to create
good content that's always the question
so let's talk about some best practices
here
remember in the last segment we talked
about keyword research so we want to
perform
good keyword research why because we
want to choose keywords
remember we're choosing multiple
keywords per page
one keyword could be related to our
brand
one keyword could be related to the
content but another key word could be
related to
a user's intent like recipes if you
recall the example we use with bread
recipes
maybe somebody's looking to type in a
keyword that says
how do i make you know a bread or how do
i make a specific type of bread or how
do i make banana bread or what's the
best recipe for banana bread
they're question related and we want to
be able to answer those questions so
that's where
choosing those right keywords that's
going to respond to a user's intent
so starts with choosing the right
keywords so
remember we talked about a number of
different tools when we talked about
keyword research so
there's a research tool that you can use
called
phrase.io and that will help you do
quick research
on you know keywords and trends and
whatnot so
if you know about a research tool that
you use for keyword research then drop
us a comment below i'd be interested in
getting your comments
about keyword research and what research
tools are out there
so if you know something better than
phrase.io drop a comment below
and we'd be interested in getting your
perspective so
keyword research is key but creating
content that fulfills
users requirements so answering those
questions if it's a recipe
we want to answer that question if it's
directions we want to answer that
question
if they don't know how to do something
we want to answer that question that's
the whole idea
behind content content is not just to
fill
a page it's to really fulfill users
requirements
that's when you get good engagement so
if somebody's typing in something on
google and they're looking for an answer
your content should answer that question
but we also want to make the content
readable
so in other words you know write for
your audience
don't impress anybody with very high
vocabulary type words that somebody
doesn't necessarily know the meaning of
don't use
jargon don't use a street language for
example
use everyday common language that's just
easily
digestible when your audience is reading
and then we want to keep that
content organized and so when we mean
organize we want to use headers and sub
headers
you know break your content into
paragraphs keep the flow
organized if we can keep the flow
organized then it's going to be
easier for somebody to read and then
it's okay to add resources
especially resources from credible sites
so if you can incorporate those
resources
in there then it's just going to add the
credibility to your content let the
audience know that hey
i've done my research on this topic and
this is what this person has to say
about it
this person who seems to be credible
okay so it only adds value to your
content
so these are all tips to remember when
creating content and then the
one important tip here is we want to use
white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques
that means you know if we've chosen
keywords that
are going to answer somebody's question
we don't want to stuff those keywords
into the content
we want the content to be naturally
written so when we say op for white hack
uh techniques that's what we mean write
the content
naturally keep it organized keep it
readable
include third-party sources and make
sure it answers a question
so they're different types of content so
there's content where you just write
words to install
text based you could also use an
infographic an infographic is simply
just a graphic
that visualizes exactly what you're
trying to
explain for example if we want to
write an article about how to
write good engaging content we don't
necessarily have to write all that out
as a text we can create an infographic
so for example here's an infographic on
20 effective ways to basically
not bore your readers but write engaging
content so you could see this is an
infographic
it's all graphically laid out so
infographics tend to be
easier to understand because they're
visual
they're easy for the end user to
comprehend because
there's generally no jargon it's usually
images that are portraying the points
of what you're trying to get across and
so it tends to break it up the monotony
of just
text it's more visually appealing and
it's laid out and organized so you can
see this infographic
has 20 different steps or rules and they
lay those out all here
in this infographic and the great thing
i like about infographics is you could
you could share them on social media
you can re-engage them as a post you
could save them on really any social
platform
so infographics tend to tell a better
story
and versus say just writing text you can
use video and images
so you don't necessarily have to lay it
all out in an infographic
you can certainly insert a video or an
image into your content especially if
it's a blog post if it's a blog post
then sometimes video and images on its
own
tell the story you don't necessarily
need
text to go ahead and
tell your story a video or an image as
they say
tells a thousand words and so images and
videos are
great to use in a blog post so using
different
forms of content you know you always
want to review your content
when a user dwells on your web page for
a longer time
google will tend to think okay this
person's engaged so we're going to rank
that favorably
so if you're using infographics videos
and images
then the chances of somebody being more
engaged are going to
increase versus just text that's not
well organized
and written out in a way that somebody
doesn't necessarily understand
so be creative in the types of content
you use
so longer engaging content tends to
bode well with search engines so
this is according to hubspot so the more
word count you use the more words you
use the chances of you ranking higher
are going to be better just take into
account
best practices you want to maybe break
up the content
with an image organize it make it
engaging use headers
so it's not necessarily just words it's
the words and how those words are
written
how they're structured the types of
keywords you're using
how you're engaging with your audience
there's a lot of factors again
there's best practices we just went over
but the key is
you know if you have longer more
engaging content
then it's going to bode better for you
on
search engines so a couple of steps to
create
high quality content so you want to
begin with a comprehensive introduction
so always introduce your content
remember the content should be relevant
to the keywords so
if you're choosing keywords and your
keyword research think about
answering that question if somebody's
typing in bread recipes maybe they're
looking for banana bread recipes
how to make the best banana bread or how
to make banana bread using dried figs
we want to be able to align our content
with that keyword naturally
you want to create a title that's worthy
that's click worthy so remember
if you're in google search and you're
doing search for
something simple like bread recipes we
want to
make something that's going to be you
know engaging for somebody to click on
like
easy perfect yeast bread or easy crusty
french bread or something that's going
to be engaging
you know the best bread recipes or how
to make the best homemade bread
you know something that's going to draw
somebody's attention to the title
of that blog post so we want to include
lsi keywords so what i mean by lsi
keywords in your content
we mean you know long tail keywords make
it
natural headings and subheadings should
consist of keywords and variants so
if you're writing headers and subheaders
include the keyword in there and that
way the content always stays relevant to
the audience
okay shorten your sentences and
paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easy for the
end user to read
and we want to always put
internal links on our blog post why
because if we have internal links then
if we
have a link from one blog post to
another blog post or say
our blog post to an internal page on our
website
we want to make sure that it's relevant
content that way
somebody's reading something and you
have an internal link
let's just say from a bread recipes page
to
a banana bread recipes page then they
may find it interesting click on that
link and go to the banana bread recipes
page
so it's keeping somebody engaged on your
website so putting in
internal linking will help keep the
end user engaged because you're offering
up links that's relevant to the content
you always want to break up that content
with images okay we want to use
alt tags meaning we want to pen the
image
with text so that way if the image
doesn't load
then at least the alt text will load so
we can incorporate call out boxes
and more importantly we want to update
our content regularly
so we always want to get the best recipe
out there if it's banana bread
or different ways to create banana bread
or always just
coming up with ways to update the
content so we want to keep our content
our blog post
fresh and then we want to include a cta
call to action
if we include a call to action then
that's going to
keep somebody engaged and have them act
on your content so these are
steps to creating high quality content
and so let's look at an example here and
this is a three month old post on
buzzfeed
and it's 21 pictures that restore your
faith in humanity so it has a lot of
likes a lot of tweaks
and that means it's engaged people are
engaged when reading that
and so if we go and look at it as an
example we can see it on a buzzfeed here
21 pictures that will restore your faith
in humanity so
this was written back in 2012 again a
lot
of engagement but if we look at it
we can see immediately that it's taking
into account
third-party sources it's got some
content it's got images
it's being broken up by images we can
see there's call to actions on there in
the form of social so people can go
ahead
and go ahead and share it if they like
it
okay it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because
listen you know it's engaging content
it's probably answering somebody's
question about humanity
and we could see clearly that look you
know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take
action on this content so not just video
not just images but text as well
and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available
so this is a good post in that regard so
content's updated regularly it's
engaging
and it includes sources from high
authority websites
some do's and don'ts on the content so
take into account the best practices i
mentioned
about creating high quality content
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear
you know because that likely is going to
be their search
and so you want to be able to respond to
the end user
that's part of creating high quality
content different types of
content i.e in the form of infographics
or videos or text
or images you can add images from public
domain sites
you can be relatable and use examples to
clarify points just like the buzzfeed
article
simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language
talk to your audience as if you they
were standing right in front of you
and use bullet points to exemplify your
examples
your points so some do's the don'ts
obviously
don't lift content we don't want to
lift content from another website so
that's plagiarism so we want to have our
own unique content
we also don't want to take images from
other websites
and so if you do happen to find an image
that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website
ideally that's not a good situation but
if you do happen to do that then always
give
credit to the website okay so if you
took it from
xyz.com credit xyz.com for the image
and even put a link back but ideally you
don't want to take images
from other websites just as much as you
don't want to take copy you don't want
to take
images use your own imagery and content
but
if you don't have imagery then you can
always go to
stock photography there are plenty of
websites out there where you can sign up
for a subscription
like adobe stock images as an example
you can sign up for an account and in
some cases you can sign up for a free
account
and use stock imagery okay don't give
less information to your audience give
them to your audience what they deserve
which is the information they're looking
for they're looking for the best banana
bread recipes give them the best banana
bread recipes
incorporate your own images break it up
with titles
give them a good quality piece of
content that they're going to be able to
engage with
and so if you put long paragraphs
in your content then it's going to be
less engaging so
try to avoid those long paragraphs
remember shorten up the paragraphs
keep the language simple add in images
answer those questions use third-party
credible sources
but write it in your own words and you
should be on your way to creating good
quality content
creating high quality videos and some of
the best practices around that
so along with everything we mentioned
about choosing the right keywords
we always need to keep in mind that the
videos we create need to be of high
quality
so the content itself in addition to the
keywords this
is a primary factor in ranking so in
order to
have keywords we need to have content
and in order to rank
we need to have you know good content so
let's talk a little bit about
creating content and what's involved
with that and
what we really mean by high quality
videos so if you have a video content
that
is not informative or relevant to the
topic it won't rank so that's just
common sense so
you need to create content that's
aligned with the topic
obviously and then that way you have
keywords that are in line with the
content
so but if you have content it really
isn't aligned with the topic
then you're not going to rank no matter
how much you've optimized that video
so just keep that in mind so there's a
couple of things we want to look at here
so high quality content is determined by
really two metrics so we're not sure
about how good our
content is and how good of high quality
video we created
we want to look at audience retention
and user engagement
so audience retention is simply the
percentage
length of your video that the audience
has watched it's the percentage
your audience has watched so focusing on
audience retention
is important for people who want their
videos to rank high
so if you want to rank you need to
optimize for the keywords but
got to keep in mind content so content
is related to audience retention
and user engagement so audience
retention percentage length
your video of your video that the
audience has watched
and for example it can be both absolute
in minutes or percentages so audience
retention can be
the average view duration or percentage
of the audience that watched then we
have user engagement
so yours are engagement viewers who are
engaged with your content
and so that means they're either sharing
it subscribing
commenting or liking so those are all
forms of engagement
so the percentage of users who watched
or
how long they watched versus engagement
or in combination with engagement
are two factors for ranking so let's
talk about some tips
for creating high quality videos so we
want to publish
longer videos and so what do we mean
behind longer videos so what's the
reason for longer videos
let's just suppose we have two videos
one shorter
in length and one longer in length first
video is 15 minutes long
the second video is seven minutes long
so on average if
viewers watch about 40 of both videos
then video x which is 15 minutes long
will have more than twice the watch time
of the video that's seven minutes long
so remember
duration we want you know people to
watch our videos longer so if the video
is longer in length
if it's 40 then it's gonna have a longer
audience engagement audience retention
so that's one of the reasons
you know from a metric standpoint so
even when viewers watch
you know both videos the time is going
to differ so
we want to take into account longer
videos for
primarily that reason is because you
know it gives an
end user an opportunity to watch the
video longer and then it's going to help
us
rank our videos longer so we talk about
watch time so if one video has
higher watch time than the other watch
time is just the number of views
times the average view duration so
another tip is we want to plan our video
script so we want to
keep the content organized my
recommendation is
you know create an outline first and
once you create an outline of how the
video is going to flow
then start populating with content and
so to me
that's how you can keep the flow
organized
okay is really with an outline starting
out with it on holidays no
videos are no different than say a
presentation if you've done a powerpoint
presentation
you always want to start out doing an
outline then we want to upload
high resolution videos high resolution
we don't want to create videos that you
know are small resolution like say
you know 400 by 400 resolution or
something you know something really
small we want to create something a very
high res
so according to back or link more than
50
of videos on the first page of youtube
are high definition
so high definition videos of higher
quality
are going to be shown on the first page
of youtube
more often than not so high resolution
videos
organizing the content publishing longer
videos
are examples of creating high quality
videos we also
want to make sure that content is
relevant to the title
so if we're talking about machine
learning basics you know obviously the
content is going to be about
you know intro to machine learning or
what is machine learning
and then the title should reflect that
content so
aligning the title sets the expectation
for the end user so
when they see a title what is machine
learning then
when they watch the video they're
expecting to learn about
machine learning and what it is so if it
meets expectations then the chances are
that person who's watching the video is
going to watch it longer
and that means it's going to fulfill the
viewers requirements
and when you align everything
accordingly keywords
titles content then at the end of the
day
the user's going to watch it and the
more they watch it the higher the
engagement the higher the engagement the
better chance you have to rank
some other tips that you could use to
create high quality videos
so we want to be able to you know use
examples to clarify our content so
you know don't be afraid to go into
another screen like i am
i want to i'm talking about videos jump
into the machine learning basics video
which i've done throughout this session
i can simply do that by keeping the user
engaged here
this video is about machine learning
basics well the title is online
with the video we made sure that we have
a nice description about what the video
is about
and we're aligning the expectations so
not only that i'm showing you example
within the video itself so
we want to use examples throughout your
video to keep the user engaged it will
also help clarify
what you're trying to express in the
video itself so we want to make it
visually appealing
so visually appealing means imagery or
examples in the video and then when we
talk about imagery
you know you want to use good images in
your video
so use public domain sites that are
available to you like shutterstock
or flat icon i mean there are plenty of
those sites out there
so feel free to use any one of those
sites
to use high quality images
in your video give more information to
your audience giving maximum
relevant information can help gain more
views
and so when we talk about more
information again it goes back to
you know examples you use there's no
should be no shortage of examples
here description use all 5 000
characters at your disposal
imagery we want to build up as much
information as you can
in the video itself to keep the end user
the viewer engaged
we also want to create original content
so always create original content
you could certainly get ideas from
youtube if you want to create a video
about machine learning
see what else has already been done do
searches on youtube itself but
you know when you're going to create a
video yeah you can create another video
about
what is machine learning but just make
sure it has your own take on it
you're the subject matter expert when
creating the video create it with your
own original content
have high audio quality and video
effects so
just like you see here on this video we
have effects in it
and the audio is of high quality meaning
no background noise no distortion and we
want to be able to speak clearly
in the video so you want to speak
clearly loudly
concise just as i'm trying to do now so
that you can
understand what i'm trying to say or
what the viewers trying to
to understand when they're watching the
video so watching and listening
are two of the components and you want
to make sure both of our high quality
avoid distractions we don't want to
pause
you don't want to ramble on a particular
point too long we want to keep
users engaged so you always want to move
from one point to the other
intermix it with examples those are ways
to keep the users
engaged we want to include transcripts
or subtitles
for your video so transcripts is just
more
content that's aligned with the video
and the search engines will be able to
pick up that content and help your video
rank so to me that's a key
component to creating a good video is
having
the necessary content to go along with
the video
that outline i referenced earlier in
terms of organization
you always want to have a content
outline so what topics are you going to
cover in the video that's
why you need the outline to point that
out confirm that before you actually
start creating the video okay focus on
the initial
15 seconds so that's key you know
somebody's going to click the play
button of your video
and if you don't catch them in the first
15 seconds then they're likely going to
pause the video or just go ahead and
close it out altogether
so you want to be able to capture
somebody's attention
right off the bat and even before they
click on that play button
you want to make sure again you're
exceeding expectations that
title is aligned with the content so in
your first 15 seconds
it basically needs to be catchy but also
setting the expectation of what the user
is expecting
so in this example here we want to pay
close attention to the first 15 seconds
that's when viewers are most likely to
drop off so
we can look at audience retention in
youtube so use the options above the
graph to view
absolute audience retention or relative
audience retention so audience retention
is basically
how many views a video received and the
percentage of the total number of video
views
and that includes every moment of the
video as a percentage so
we'll show you an example of what that
looks like so here if we go to the
machine learning basics
video we can look at the audience
retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it
and how long they viewed it so in
percentage so here for example i can see
you know 43 44 watch the video
for at least two minutes here i can see
28.6
watch it for six minutes plus so that's
the audience retention it gives us an
idea in terms of percentage how many
people
or percentage of people watch the video
at what length so that's audience
retention
so we want to keep that number high at
the very
initial stage of the video and we want
to keep it high throughout
and that's why you always want to create
high quality content using those
examples
using imagery making it organized
content
not pausing you know going from one
point to the other those are all
best practices to keep the viewer
engaged and then we want to add
resources from well-known sites
so throughout this video we've used
backlinko
there are other sources we've used so if
you have a source go ahead and put it in
your video to add credibility
and then we want to use cards to your
videos so this cards is basically a
feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to
machine learning basics there could be
other videos about machine learning
that we can recommend or youtube can
recommend to the audience
to set up end screens you want to make
sure that
with end screens you can use relevant
videos to your audience
towards the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos
towards the end of your video you can
also create playlists
so this is a feature that keeps your
audience engaged with relevant content
by
autoplaying the next video so if you
enable this feature
it's going to go from one video to
another pattern interrupts
keep the audience engaged so basically
it allows your audience to stay within
one video
without having any interruptions
involved and so
going back to the did you know audience
retention report helps you analyze how
well your videos are engaging to the
audience
so what do we mean by that well if i go
back again to my audience retention
report
how engaging was it well i could see 42
percent
43 watched it on average of 3 minutes
and 21 seconds
so to me that's pretty good of course we
always 100
of the video the video is seven minutes
long if
almost half of our audience saw over
half of the video
then i would say that's pretty good
people were engaged
so audience retention just is a good
report to start looking at to help you
understand
how engaging is my video if your video
is not engaging
you know you can always go back and edit
it or fix it or tweak it so remember
the average view duration for all videos
and top performing videos listed by all
time
we can look at that information as well
in addition we can look at demographics
so we can get an overview of the age
gender and location
okay we can look at playback locations
report and what the playback locations
report does
is it helps us determine the platforms
where our videos are being streamed from
within youtube look at the traffic
sources where did
the viewers come from devices did they
look on mobile or tablet
and so if there's any doubts you know if
you have any questions
please drop a comment below but
especially if you have any doubts on the
metrics so if we go back
into youtube we can look at analytics
and if we're looking at analytics we can
see more
and then this is going to show us
everything we need to see
from device type so if i click on more i
can see my
playback location so this will show me
where the video was watched
it was on a watch page or a channel page
i could see the traffic sources
i could see the gender and age so if i
click on
the viewer age report i can see the
percentage of views by age
so i can get a lot of information about
my video and how it's performed who's
watched it
what they've done with it uh where they
come from all the information they need
to know okay so it's all within youtube
analytics
so again if you have any questions about
that you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to youtube you
may have some questions but
just know that every video you publish
to youtube
high quality align with your keywords
you're going to be able to view
the metrics by looking at youtube
analytics
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is content marketing
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves the creation
and sharing of online content to help
generate
audience interest in a brand's product
or services
this means providing information that
the audience considers valuable and
relevant
in a consistent manner so that it drives
some sort of profitable customer action
so let's talk about the content that
falls under content marketing
there's options like blogs videos
infographics case studies white papers
and ebooks so why is content marketing
so important
firstly it helps build awareness trust
and loyalty in your brand the more your
brand provides
accurate and well-researched content the
more people learn about and trust your
brand
the more the audience trusts in you the
more they're likely to buy from you
creating the content is relatively
inexpensive and can be done in-house
content marketing will also enable your
brand to increase
traffic to your site and get more
conversions
it also helps improve other marketing
tactics
like search engine optimization social
media and public relations
now let's have a look at the content
marketing process
the first step is to determine what
goals you want to achieve with your
marketing campaign
it could be increased conversions
website signups and so on
then you set up buyer personas from
among your
audience that can buy your content but
what exactly are buyer personas
now these are research-based profiles
that represent your target customer
buyer personas help you describe your
brand's ideal audience
the decisions they make the challenges
they face their interests and so on
next you'll have to set up content
audits to determine the best type of
content that works for you
you also need to set up a content
management system like hubspot
squarespace wix and wordpress they'll
help you with increased collaboration
greater support run a b test and much
more
you need to brainstorm for new forms of
content that your audience can enjoy
after that you can zero in on a
particular form of content
that would work the best for you and
finally
you can publish and manage your content
now let's talk about content marketing
tips
number one remarket your content content
marketing is one of the many ways you
can spread your content
to a binder audience you can define the
audience you want to market to
and then tag visitors who come to your
site and using google's display network
you can strategically position your ads
in front of people on google
or its partner websites who previously
interacted with your website and
advertised to them
through this you can build awareness and
engagement with your audience
here's an example of a banner
advertisement i would be shown if i was
shopping for a macbook pro on amazon
and changed my mind at the last moment
this ad would maybe stay at the back of
my head
until eventually i go and finish that
purchase
now let's go to number two answering
complex questions with your content
targeting specific keywords is extremely
helpful with your content
this is why you need to focus on
google's featured snippet
this position also known as position 0
enhances
and draws user attention on the search
engine's result
page through the featured snippet you
can drive a large amount of traffic to
your website
while cementing your position as an
expert in your industry
you can have different forms of snippets
like
definition boxes where a snippet of text
gives
researchers direct and concise
definitions and descriptions
you could have tables where data is
taken from the page and displayed in a
table
you could have ordered lists where items
are presented in specific order
and you can also have unordered lists
next up number three we have create a
personality for your brand
if you're looking to grow a following
for your content try not to copy how
already established and successful
corporate blogs do things
nowadays audiences tend to prefer
content that has a certain humanness
about it
tend to follow solo influencers they
advertise their brand by being
themselves
in a way they're selling themselves by
being themselves
you need to analyze what these popular
and influential blogs are doing
and incorporate into your brand's
website
thanks to this your audience will
connect with you and come back for more
now here's an example of one of the
largest players in digital marketing
neil patel see how he himself is the
brand
and if you've gone through his content
you know it's pretty great as well
that's what you should be striving for
moving on to tip number four
ensure that your content matches your
brand's voice
to make sure of this you need to
constantly review your editorial
standards
and make sure your tone and quality
remain consistent
you need to ask your audience questions
about how you can develop
and refine your brand's voice by
answering these questions
you can provide your audience with a
more cohesive and helpful experience
your tone of your brand can vary on the
basis of what type of content you are
planning to post
and what the goal you want to achieve
from the campaign
next up we have number five back up your
arguments for data
using statistics and facts to make a
point by including a link to the
original source
makes it extremely credible this data
can help the audience grow trust in your
brand
to persuade them that your content is
valid and valuable
this will also help your brand grow as
an industry expert
at number six we have use specific
keywords
now make sure you use specific keywords
in your content
this takes care of the seo aspect behind
your content
this will also help your content have a
greater chance of being found
indexed and ranked it could also help
your content rank for niche topics
within your industry
moving on to tip number seven evaluate
the success of your content
with data earlier we talked about why
it's so important
that you back up your content with data
now let's talk about how data can help
you improve
analytics tools will help you learn more
about
how well your content is doing the age
demographics of the people enjoying it
who doesn't their locations the best
time to post and much
more with this data you can make sure
that your time and money
are being used in the best possible way
some of the most popular tools in the
market
are buzzsumo evernote hubspot
trello and wordpress these will help you
find
topics and influencers within your
industry you can capture
organize and share notes collaborate
with team members
create sales funnels and much more
now we've reached midway right now so
i've got a question for you
do you guys have any tips for content
marketing that we haven't covered yet
let me know in the live chat
alright so let's get back to our list
tip number eight
is to be consistent with your content
post your best performing content and
make sure they follow a consistent
schedule
finding a balance of the different types
of content to be posted
with the help of a content calendar will
show your audience that you're committed
to providing them helpful
and informative content this will also
establish your brand as an authority
and thought leader within your niche it
will help your audience depend on you
for quality content
and give them a reason to return tip
number nine
is to make your content actionable
providing actionable steps or
information in your content
will coerce your audience to take a
particular action
quickly it can help you create
value-built content
and fix pain points faced by your
audience build a strong relationship
with them
and earn their trust it also leads to
increased engagement
and a positive brand experience it
provides users with real value and
solutions
leading them to take action here we have
an example
from trello where we see a pop-up with a
call to action asking interested users
to input their email ids to sign media
today
involving more than 200 marketers more
than 49 percent of them
felt content marketing was really
important to their digital marketing
campaigns
and more than 25 percent of their
budgets are used for visual advertising
content like images infographics videos
and other forms of
rich media will help you enhance the
message of your brand
and reach a wider audience here's an
example
of advertising by coca-cola although
there's not a lot of text in the ads
you can immediately recognize the
unmistakable
branding and the message they're trying
to send moving on to tip number 11
create trending and evergreen content
creating content that's evergreen and
trending
with your own unique angle statistics
and research
will be a huge advantage since you'll
have to update it every now and then
you'll get a great deal out of the work
without having to do a lot of work
here's an example of one such evergreen
article
people are never going to stop wanting
to learn how to do seo
so with a little tweaking every few
months to reflect new changes that
google may have done
you'll have an article that you can get
considerable mileage out of
next up tip number 12 is to understand
content that works for you you need to
analyze
what content works on different social
media platforms
for example you all know youtube is the
best place for video content
instagram and pinterest for visual
content twitter for smaller snappy
content and so on
understanding what works and what
doesn't will help you better spread your
content
across the internet tip number 13
is to understand your target audience
now like i mentioned earlier your
marketing campaign
isn't going to bear fruit without
targeting a specific audience
understanding who your audience is is
one of the most important steps for this
you can find this out by asking
questions like who you're engaging with
online their age location language etc
by using social listening to find out
what audiences are talking about your
brand
using tools to research what social
channels your audience
is using and so on after understanding
them
you can set up buyer personas for your
audience
tip number 14 is to perform a b testing
now abs testing will help you understand
what your audience likes
or doesn't what content works for you
and much more
you can do a b testing on headlines and
title tags
call to actions content formats image
types
content length and much more it can also
help you make better decisions in the
future
and finally our tip number 15 is to
reach out to people
sharing similar content one of the best
ways to build your
audience is to get people or influencers
who already share
content within your niche to share your
content
now since these people already have a
trusting audience
they would be a lot more likely to enjoy
your content
content marketing interview questions
and
answers so thanks for joining again and
here's how it's gonna work
so if you have any questions to these
questions or answers feel free
to just comment right below this video
and we'll
get back to you as soon as possible
we're going to go through a series of
questions and i'm going to answer those
questions for you
starting out what are the essential
components of
a good web content okay so essential
components
okay so what do we want our content to
do well we want it to be useful
so web content should be written in a
way which caters
to what the reader wants okay so
somebody's not going to read your
content if it's not useful for them
okay this because it affects reader
engagement okay so if it's not
interesting
it's not useful somebody's just not
going to read it plain and simple
it also has to be engaging so listen
even if it
is relevant to a user you still have to
write the content
so it's engaging so you want to add
elements like
imagery videos hey you can even turn
your content into an infographic
okay you want to do something that's
going to be engaging for the user if
it's engaging
they're going to read it and engage with
the content okay and then
good content should have some call to
action so content must be written in a
way that can drive
call to action okay so if you're writing
a blog post
you know i've seen a lot of blog posts
just simply start
and with good content but it doesn't
leave a user with anywhere to go
so have that call to action put some
internal links in that content give
somebody a place to go after they're
done engaging
with the good content that you write
okay so some other things to think about
some other components for good
content well credibility so you know
anybody can write
but are you writing about something you
know what you're writing about are you
a good talking point a good expert or
have experience about this content
so you also want to use you know
information from a legitimate source
okay so you don't want to grab something
in your and use it in your content
that's just not legitimate because it
does
hurt your credibility and the
organization's credibility
and then also originality i mean write
something
that nobody else has written so
obviously you don't want to plagiarize
because if you plagiarize and there are
tools out there where people can easily
just put their content in there to see
what else is out there see if somebody
else has plagiarized it so it's very
easy
to find people who plagiarize so don't
be that person
what i would recommend create a good
content calendar and come up with some
ideas before you write them
next question related to content
marketing so what are the types of
content you can create
well there are a lot of things you can
create start with the blog
blog to me is always a great place to
start it's a blank canvas
for your ideas your thoughts your
opinions okay that's a great thing about
a blog it accentuates personality
you can create a video videos are always
engaging
you can create an infographic
infographics to me are
you know hidden gem instead of somebody
reading the same old same old
you're laying this out in a very visual
way
that's easy to understand create a case
study
okay so if you're a digital marketing
expert
you've done social media for another
client you know write about it you know
show
the successes show that you are an
expert show that you've created
successful campaigns and social and in
the form of case study you can create a
white paper white papers are
good educational pieces you can also
create an ebook
okay ebook hey if you have a lot of
content you want to lay it out
and ebook's a good way to go and you
have a lot of choices here when it comes
to content a lot of choices okay so what
are the advantages of having a content
counter so i alluded to that just a
couple of seconds ago
so let's really break this down here
because content counters to me
are so important well first of all
calendar part of content calendar allows
you to think about dates so
if you're planning something you're
going to have important dates in mind
okay so content calendar it almost
ensures you don't miss anything
you know that's a good opportunity for
you to leverage
like you know black friday cyber monday
you know it's probably important you
know when those days are
if you're in e-commerce so that's why
having a content calendar helps it helps
you plan
out your content based on important
dates
or based on dates that work for what
you're trying to do
they also help because you could stick
to a consistent schedule
okay so if you don't have a content
calendar you're probably just
arbitrarily writing content here and
there
well what if your users crave and really
engage with the content they're going to
want more
sticking to something consistent is
going to really get people
come back for more they know when you're
going to post they're going to be
waiting for it and if it's every tuesday
morning eight o'clock hey
post it tuesday morning eight o'clock
your users will get used to that
schedule
and it does help build up your following
it does help
help build up your community and in the
end cultivates a long-lasting
relationship
and then having a content calendar also
allows you to mix
up your content okay so you can see and
plan ahead
different types of content in different
formats
that way it allows you to mix it up
whether it be a blog post
a an infographic a video about different
topics
okay some other advantages here saving
time
it just allows you to prepare for the
future when you can prepare
you're efficient and when you're
efficient you're not wasting time
and so to me having a content calendar
is a must
because a lot of us are busy who has
time
especially if you're going to work in a
new company
so let's say writing content you
definitely want to have a content
counter because you're going to want to
use that time
to efficiently plan this is a new
company you're going to start working at
you want to understand
who this company is what they've done in
the past what you haven't done
and what you want to do okay so all of
that helps you plan
and prepare and it saves you the time
and effort and hassle down the road
and then at the end of the day you want
to be able to figure out what works so
planning your post
puts less strain on you and your team
members as well as company resources
because when you plan and you post
you're going to get data
and then when you get data it's either
going to work or not work and if it
doesn't work then you know in the future
you're not going to put that
piece of content or the topic in the
content calendar again
it's that simple okay some other
advantages
fresh content okay so having a con
content calendar allows you to always
keep content fresh
can you're going to be on a consistent
schedule and you're not going to be
writing about the same things over and
over again
so it could be just simply twitter if
you're putting a content calendar in
it together for twitter well you don't
want to have the same tweets
every other day so it does ensure that
you're getting tweets out there that are
fresh that are new that are different
and again figure out what works a
content counter makes it easier to
measure results and optimize performance
so you
always want to you know maybe put some
metrics in with your content calendar
so you can see side by side content
historically that is performed content
that is not performed
okay so next question you may get what
type of content
works in each stage of the customer life
cycle so you have awareness
engagement purchase post-purchase
advocacy okay so let's
break these down here so awareness okay
so you want people to understand who you
are
okay that could be a guest blog an
influencer helping yell
it could be a cold email a v a video
that can potentially go viral
a social media post introducing a
product
you have engagement so you want people
to engage with your content what are you
going to do to get people to engage well
you could certainly write an email and
have people open that email and go to
your website
you can have an ebook where people can
actually download and read it
or you can have a blog where people can
comment or landing page where they can
fill out a form submission you have
evaluation so
with social media we know there's a lot
of engagement going on
but when you're putting content out
there you can certainly
open it up to testimonials okay you can
generate white papers
okay or you can generate case studies
case studies a good way for companies to
evaluate what you've done in the past
if you've worked in a for a specific
product in the past and it's worked
you certainly want to put that out there
for potential clients in that same
industry
purchase trying to get people to
purchase what are you gonna do well you
can certainly have landing pages a nice
you know website a nice shopping cart
with some nice content okay
onboarding emails get those emails out
there and get people to
go back to the website and purchase of
course you can have product and service
details as well
meaning you know one one page
downloadable
pdfs that describe the product okay a
post purchase
okay so people who've already purchased
you could certainly send out follow-up
emails
and you can do blog round-ups you know
give people an opportunity to see
what features or updates are happening
to the product
okay of course case studies of repeat
customers
or content types that detail a new
feature or
service okay so if somebody's already
purchased and you may want to send them
some content of another product
that complements the product they bought
so a lot of things you can do
to engage with your user who's already
purchased and then advocacy you want
people to help you out here
so have the user generate the content
you can have
exclusive discounts for your community
they're going to be your advocates so
give them exclusive discounts and then
pictures of customers
engaging with your products okay who's
not gonna share that so you're gonna
have people
share that information in other words
you can generate content
where hey people can help you out here
and be your advocate okay so how do you
decide what topic and subject to write
on okay well
going back to the content counter that
always helps you to see
what you put in that content calendar
but there are some other methods you can
use
and you could certainly identify your
target audience and not only identify
your target audience but what their
needs are
okay so you can write content based on
audience you could certainly
do some research with keywords okay
what's trending what keywords are not
trending okay
and right around what's trending for
example okay you could certainly take a
look at social media for example cora i
always look at korra
core is interesting entertaining
informational
hey people are certainly having
conversations on core and you can
certainly analyze those conversations
because they certainly get in depth and
you can decide hey do i want to write a
topic around something that
really just won't go away in terms of
conversing core is a good example of
analyzing conversations they tend to be
a little bit more in-depth
so some other things you could do you
can look at your competitors
and what kind of conversations are
happening on your competitors
blogs or your competitors social media
platforms
and pages you can keep track of blogs
and articles from subject matter experts
commentators critics and so on
okay so you can get ideas from them
another question you may get which is
very important if you're going to start
working for a company you
need to understand the tone the tone of
your content because that
is going to fit and be in line with the
company you're working for okay so
you're always going to have a brand
personality so the characteristics of a
brand are the guidelines based on which
the content strategy is developed the
tone of the content must align itself to
the content
strategy your audience profile so you're
gonna you need to determine who your
audience is
okay and how the brand wants to be seen
by that audience
so you know if you have an older
audience you're not going to use
younger audience i.e street lingo
or today's lingo and and the younger
generation
you're going to use you know language
that's going to fit the audience you're
talking to
and then of course the channel itself so
the content you create
must be irrespective of the channel and
consistent with brand attributes
okay so you gotta pick and choose the
channel if it's linkedin for example
hey you know linkedin is more business
oriented okay so you're not gonna be
you know as humorous as you would be say
on instagram or facebook
all of these have one thing in common
again that's brand guidelines you have
to stay
within the brand what is the brand's
personality
how do we want to talk to our audience
and what platform are we using to talk
to our audience
how do you promote your content once
it's live
well that's always a good question hey
you doing the the work the
putting in the hard work to create this
you know it could be a video and videos
take a long time
it could be an infographic an ebook okay
so
send it out via email okay if you have
an email list send it out and let people
know this content's there
put a link in the email or even a piece
or snippet or preview
of the content in the email so you're
using the email to broadcast and
encourage people to
you know if it's an ebook get the rest
of the ebook okay you could certainly
leverage social media to engage with
your community
that's the best you know just as good as
email get out there and let people know
hey i got
i got my book published come and
download it you know you can give a
discount to the first
100 people that download it okay you can
always promote
your content via ads so whether that be
google or facebook
you always have an opportunity to meet
more prominent
by advertising the content that you have
to offer so you can always reach out on
social media
again targeting interesting people
directly
so you can always interact with people
on social
or you can write for others attract
people from the web to important pages
of your website by guest posting
so you can always go on to a popular
blog post and write something and
you know link it up or or have it be
relevant to the content you've written
so next question how can you determine
how well your content is doing okay
very important again you've done all the
work
you've put the content calendar together
you got the content
ready to go it's published you're
promoting it
social email guest blogging but you want
to determine
how it's doing well depends on the
channel really is what it comes down to
so if it's
organic search you want to be able to
see if it's ranking for the keywords you
optimize that content for
if it's social you want to be able to
see if you have engagement
shares comments etc of course you can
always look at analytics
and see how much traffic that blog post
is getting
or that page with the white paper is
getting
okay so you can always look at your
analytics and look at the traffic
okay and again you can always look to
see if there are
conversions in the form of an inquiry or
lead or sale
so at the end of the day you want to
align the content with the channel
and you want to align the kpi with the
content and channel okay
so if it's social you're not likely
going to get conversions unless you're
doing paid ads
if you're posting organically on social
then you're probably going to get some
engagement
so you have to align the right metric
with the right channel
what are the steps involved in the
content marketing process
okay so you really need to decide what
goal you want to achieve with the
content marketing campaign so that goes
back to what i was just saying a minute
ago
if you have content you post it on
social then what's the goal what are you
trying to achieve
well you're probably going to get
engagement and likes you need to define
buyer personas to determine the audience
best suited for your content
okay so you're always writing for an
audience and you're going to market
that content for that audience so you
always got to keep that in mind
okay run content audits audits to
determine the best type of content
that can be used in other words how did
it perform
what kind of engagement did you get with
the infographic or
did that video really really perform
well or do we want to use
you know a blog post next time around or
an image next time around
so continuing on here you want to choose
an appropriate
content management system okay so how
are we managing all this content
okay is it wordpress or is it another
platform
okay you could start brainstorming for
ideas for new content
so again that goes back to the content
calendar you leverage your content
counter
to always create ideas for new content
okay then you want to settle
on a particular type of content that you
want to create okay so once you
come up and you're managing your content
you you come up with some ideas then you
obviously want to
choose the format and then of course you
want to publish and manage your content
after it's all said and done
so these are the steps involved again
just quickly
decide on the goal the kpi deciding your
audience
look at what's worked and not worked in
the past get your content set up in the
platform
okay or get the platform ready to go i
should say okay
generate ideas with that content counter
i ideally go to the content
calendar for the ideas choose that type
and then
publish and manage and when i say manage
i mean again
going back to analytics or going back to
the kpi that you
align with that content to see if it's
performing or not okay so next question
here
how do you target the right audience for
your content it's a very good question
you're not writing content for everyone
let's be honest here
so you have to collect demographics of
your target audience based on
who's coming to your website based on
who subscribed to your emails
based on who's following you on social
media so in other words you have people
interacting with you okay in different
channels and you need to understand who
these people are
so are they fit a certain age range your
generation
are they skewed more female to male
education level
what's their affinity or interest okay
do they have a certain income
so you need to really break down your
audience here and you could do that
in analytics you could do that on social
you can do that just by looking at your
email list
okay the all those will paint a picture
as to who your audience is
i'm greg jarbo i'm a member of the
market motive faculty
in this first section we're going to
talk about what content marketing is
how it works and also explore why it
works
it seems like a new buzzword to you it's
actually a term that's been around for
quite some time it's just web search
interest in content marketing has
tripled
since 2010 according to google trends
and that's why a lot of people are now
just starting to get their arms around
it
so what is content marketing well
according to rebecca lee a friend of
mine who wrote an article
in advertising age content marketing is
not just a glorified way to say social
media marketing it's actually a little
broader concept so
content marketing does include social
media and you can use blogs
facebook twitter youtube vimeo
linkedin google plus pinterest
foursquare
instagram flickr stumbleupon tumblr
slideshare and quora and you can put all
of those together
in a content marketing program and
all of this content can be optimized
so it can be found in search engines as
well as in social media
or in the usual places like your website
one of the ways to sort of conceptualize
this is the classic venn diagram
brian clark of copy blogger has put
together a really interesting white
paper called the business case for agile
content marketing in which she's created
this particular diagram that shows
search social and content and the
overlap of the three
is where he positions content marketing
and that may help you understand where
it fits it's sort of
a little bit of this a little bit of
that but it also shows you
both the potential leverage that you can
get when you begin
combining these elements but also the
potential conflicts you may encounter
inside an
organization who says hey wait a second
that's my job
and the real challenge to content
marketing is getting people who have
been doing
their job independently headed off in
their own unique direction
to actually collaborate and coordinate
what they're doing
and leveraging each other's capabilities
to create something that's a little more
powerful
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on content marketing full
course
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
about the topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here